Shanks, Mihawk, Roger. All three characters are
some of the most powerful in all of One Piece,
and they all have one thing in common. NO. DEVIL.
FRUITS. Of course they have unbelievable haki and
sword skills, but that’s not the point of this
video! Because I want to take these already
insanely overpowered characters and make them
absolutely untouchable by finding THE ABSOLUTELY
PERFECT devil fruits for all the Strongest
Non-Devil Fruit users in the entire story.
And we’re going to kick this off with possibly
the STRONGEST CHARACTER EVER! And yes, I’m of
course talking about the former pirate king,
Gol D. Roger, who mostly overwhelmed his foes
with his god-tier haki, supreme swordsmanship, and
possibly the greatest crew to ever sail the seas.
But what he NEVER HAD, as far as we know
as least, is a broken devil fruit ability.
And I’ll be honest, when thinking about
the perfect devil fruit for Roger,
the first fruit that came to mind was his
son’s devil fruit, the Flame-Flame fruit.
That’s because this Logia power is just SO
OP as it allows you to literally shoot out
flames, create giant waves of fire, and
especially for a swordsman like Roger,
you can coat your blade in flames to cut
down enemies with devastating fiery slashes.
However, when actually thinking about it,
there is one devil fruit that would meet
Roger’s needs even better than the Flame fruit.
And that is of course the Nika devil fruit that
was eaten by Luffy. And for the longest time
fans thought that Roger might have already
eaten this fruit, but we don’t know for sure.
However, since we now know that awakening this
fruit allows you to become the legendary figure
Joy Boy, then we just HAVE TO give it to Roger.
That’s because when Roger and his crew finally
reached Laugh Tale, for some unknown reason they
were too early to use what they found there.
Now that could simply have been a time thing,
like they didn’t show up at the right time, or
it might have been because they needed Joy Boy
to awaken in order to use the secret treasures
left by the Ancient Kingdom. We had some hint
of this when Shanks decided to go after the
One Piece after he learned Luffy had awakened,
so giving Roger this fruit just makes too much
sense if it means he could have actually used
what he found on Laugh Tale. Plus, his personality
is so similar to Luffy’s that I’m sure he would
have eventually awakened this fruit and
made full use of its broken abilities.
Now that Roger has his fruit though, we need
one for his right hand man, Rayleigh. And
the so-called Dark King fights in basically the
exact same way as his captain BUT I have a VERY
DIFFERENT devil fruit in mind for Luffy’s mentor.
That’s because Rayleigh has almost unmatched speed
and power, but we could turn his stats all the
way up to max by giving him the Light Devil fruit,
which would allow him to move at light speeds,
swing his sword with even more devastating power,
and of course shoot off light bullets to take
out enemies from a distance. And Rayleigh has
been linked to this fruit ever since he clashed
with admiral Kizaru during the Sabaody arc,
but even though this fruit would
be PERFECT for the Dark King,
I’m actually thinking another fruit might be
better for Rayleigh during his prime years.
Because we know he was already a top tier
fighter, but one thing he couldn’t ever do
is help his captain stay alive once Roger got a
deadly disease. So what if we gave Rayleigh the
Phoenix devil fruit because of its special
healing abilities? And in case you forgot,
this fruit is a mythical zoan that turns the
user into this majestic blue Phoenix that can
fly around. But the UNBELIEVABLE special ability
of this fruit is to use these magical blue flames
to heal yourself and others. So what if by having
this ability Rayleigh could have actually cured
Roger, or if not that then maybe extend his
lifespan by giving him a regular supply of
healing flames. Plus I just think the idea of
a flying swordsman is just incredibly awesome,
so I’m giving this fruit to Rayleigh.
But as hard as it is to believe,
Roger and Rayleigh are not even the strongest
members of their own crew in this video. That’s
because we’ll be giving the perfect devil
fruit to Shanks in just a few minutes.
But before we get to the Red Haired Emperor we
first need to talk about the man who used to
hunt down the Roger Pirates, Monkey D. Garp. And
unlike Roger and Rayleigh, Luffy’s Grandpa is just
a straight up brawler who fights with his bare
knuckle fists. However, if you know anything about
the old man you’ll know those fists are basically
nuclear weapons as he can wipe out entire cities
with a single punch. So we of course have to ask,
what is the perfect devil fruit to give a man such
powerful punches? Well, first I was thinking that
the Buddha fruit, which was eaten by his friend
and former fleet admiral, makes a ton of sense.
That’s because eating this fruit would allow
Garp to transform into an enormous golden Buddha
with giant fists and the ability to send out huge
shockwaves. But I am a bit concerned this would
slow Garp down. Plus that giant body might make
Garp extra hungry, so our next contender here
is the Biscuit Fruit, which would allow him to
make an endless supply of delicious biscuits.
Because as we know, one of Garp’s favorite
foods is Rice Crackers, which I think he’d be
able to make with this devil fruit as well.
And while that would certainly satisfy his hunger
cravings, it still isn’t quite the most impressive
fruit for Garp, so let’s give him the classic
Luffy treatment, where we take his punches and
just make them bigger. And we can do that with the
Deka Deka no mi, which as we see right here allows
its user to freely change their size to make them
into enormous humans that are literally the size
of mountains. And while we earlier mentioned that
Garp being bigger was a bad thing since it would
make him slower, I’d like to think that he could
keep his normal form for speed and then change
his size right before punching someone to create
a MASSIVE impact. Which means if he can normally
destroy entire cities, then with this power he
might even be able to wipe out entire islands.
If we’re thinking about it though, Garp’s
apprentice Koby might someday surpass the
legendary marine, and to do that he might just
need the perfect devil fruit. And lucky for the
Pink haired marine, we are here to help! And these
options are just going to absolutely blow your
mind. Let’s kick it off by considering the Ice
Devil fruit, which was eaten by the former admiral
Aokiji. And ever since Aokiji left the marines
there has always been a chance he would die,
which means that Koby could in fact eat this
fruit sometime in the future. But like most
Logia’s it is just absurdly powerful,
with the ability to freeze anything,
shoot out icy blasts, and even create ice
weapons to use against opponents. What makes
this fruit truly perfect for Koby though
is that we recently learned that Aokiji was
ALSO a beloved student of Garp, so there is
some history to go with this fruit and Koby.
But if we’re being honest, Koby is more
of a fistfighter just like his mentor,
so let’s think of a fruit that will go with his
normal fighting style. And this is going to blow
your mind because with Koby’s expert levels
of haki and destructive punches, he is most
comfortable fighting at close range. But with many
devil fruit users who can fight from far away,
Koby might be at a disadvantage in many fights.
So to fix that let’s give him the ONLY DEVIL
FRUIT that can make sure you have close range
combat against other devil fruit users, which
is actually the Darkness Logia fruit, originally
eaten by Blackbeard. Which sounds crazy, I know,
but let me explain why. We all know Blackbeard’s
powers allow him to shoot out darkness and trap
people in to his black hole, but one of his
other abilities allows him to suck in devil
fruit users so he can touch them and erase
their devil fruit ability. And once he has
hold of them he can beat them down, so if we gave
this same power to Koby, he would always be able
to fight devil fruit users at close range
and deal massive blows like this. So yeah,
this power alone would make Koby one of the
most feared fighters in the entire world.
However, you can already describe this next
character that way because Dracule Mihawk is
the World’s Strongest Swordsman. And while we’ve
never actually seen him fight all out, we can just
imagine that he has top-tier haki to match his
insane sword skills, since he was said to fight
on par with Shanks back in their early days. Which
means he obviously doesn’t need a devil fruit,
but just like Koby, Mihawk’s fighting style
could also be enhanced by the Darkness fruit’s
abilities. For example, he could use his darkness
pocket dimension to store different swords and
pull them out when he needs them. Or he could use
it the same way we discussed with Koby, but since
Mihawk can send flying slashes, he doesn’t need
the ability to suck people in like Koby does.
What he does need though, is this! Because
come on, who wouldn’t have to see a winged
version of this dark swordsman flying around
and chasing down his enemies? And if we’re
talking about a fruit with wings, then
probably the best one for Mihawk would
be the Falcon fruit which was once eaten
by this Alabasta royal guard. And I know,
it’s not exactly the same as his name, I
did extra research to see if there was a
Hawk fruit to fit Mihawk’s name, but the
Falcon fruit is the closest I could find.
Speaking of Swordsmen though, this next one
is different from EVERY OTHER SWORDSMAN here
because Oden Kozuki’s two sword style was nearly
strong enough to take down the Emperor Kaido. And
while his haki levels are a tier below those
of Roger and the other top tiers on this list,
Oden is still an extremely powerful fighter
who could possibly reach the top with the
help of the perfect devil fruit. Now, picking
the perfect fruit for Oden is tough. Obviously,
any Logia would be a boost to his overall defense
and power, but based on his personality I think
a hilarious option would once again
be the Buddha fruit. I mean, come on,
Oden just seems like a guy who would love to walk
around as a giant golden Buddha. But the option
that BEST balances power, defense, and Oden’s
sword style is actually the Heat Heat fruit,
originally eaten by one of Big Mom’s children.
And I know this sounds like some kind of sick
joke since Oden was literally boiled to death, but
with the powers of the Heat Fruit, Oden might be
resistant to such high temperatures meaning that
this fruit gives him a great chance to survive the
boiling. On top of that, he could send out
MASSIVE heat waves, set people on fire, or
even add flaming heat to his impressive two-sword
style of fighting, just like this guy right here.
Now with Oden’s new blazing swords out of the
way, we can finally talk about the only Straw
Hat on this list. And while I’ve already done full
length videos on Zoro and Sanji’s perfect fruits,
I also think the Straw Hat’s helmsman, Jinbe, is a
perfect candidate for a devil fruit boost. I mean,
he’s already a powerful fighter with his mastery
of fishman karate and his ability to manipulate
water somewhat, so obviously something water or
ice-related would be perfect for him. Something
like the Ice Devil fruit would fit nicely with
his powers as he could move water around and
then freeze it at the perfect time. Another
water related ability is the Swim Swim fruit,
which we now know that Jinbe’s clone possesses,
so this would obviously be a good option as well.
However, I’m actually going to go in the
complete opposite direction now because I
think Jinbe would be THE PERFECT character to
use the Flame Flame fruit. That’s because with
his natural water manipulation techniques plus
the power of the flame fruit, Jinbe could be
a fire and water master the likes of which
the world has literally never seen before.
If you think Jinbe’s fighting style is unique
though just wait until we discuss the perfect
devil fruit for this next character. Because now
we have Lucky Roux, who is one of Shanks’ top
officers, who we honestly haven’t seen fight too
much. He obviously used a gun back in chapter 1
and in Film Red we saw him bouncing around as this
giant spinning ball. So to find his perfect fruit
is going to be quite tricky. Although we do know
he is always eating so maybe just giving him the
Cook Cook fruit is the best choice. I mean, that
would let him turn anything into food and eat it,
so that sounds good to me. Another option
to enhance his bowling ball fighting style
is to give him the Ton Ton fruit, formerly
eaten by this guy, which allows the user to
DRAMATICALLY increase their body’s weight.
I’m talking like up to 10 million Kilograms,
which roughly equal to about 10,000 cars. So
yeah, just imagine Lucky Roux smashing into
you with that kind of weight! You’d probably turn
into dust or something. However, this is Shanks’
crew we’re talking about, and I really feel like
we need something extra special here, so why not
give Lucky Roux the Light Logia fruit because I
just literally can’t help myself from smiling at
the image of Lucky Roux dashing around at the
speed of light. That kind of speed, plus all
the other insane powers of that fruit might even
let Lucky Roux defeat this next character though.
Because while Lucky Roux is undoubtedly powerful,
Shanks' right hand man, Benn Beckman has an even
more impressive reputation. He frightened an
admiral pre timeskip and is known to be both an
expert marksman, brawler, and, most importantly,
he is one of the smartest characters in the entire
story. And that fact alone probably means
that Beckman could use nearly any devil fruit
exceptionally well. Just some examples could
be the Book Book fruit that could let him trap
people in alternate dimensions, the Nine-Tailed
Fox fruit which would let him shape-shift into
other people - which just has all kinds of uses
for an intelligent person - or even Law’s Ope
Ope no mi which is one of the most complicated
fruits to learn, but also has one of the highest
potentials in the entire story. All of these would
be AMAZING choices for Shanks’ right hand man,
but there is ONE MORE FRUIT that truly fits
Beckman best. Ladies and Gentlemen, let me direct
you to the Magnet fruit. And man, this fruit
would be INSANE in Beckman’s hands. Clearly,
it is a tough fruit to use because it requires
such precise control and knowledge of machines,
but in Beckman’s hands, he could
literally create ANYTHING out of
metal. Railguns! An endless variety of weapons!
A battleship! Or if we’re really going crazy,
maybe even a giant mecha suit! Truly, this fruit
and Beckman would be a match made in heaven.
But nothing, and I mean NOTHING, compares to the
PURE MAJESTY of what is coming next. Because now
we have the Red-Haired Captain himself, Shanks.
And we’re not even going to mess around with other
options because there is only ONE FRUIT that
is ABSOLUTELY PERFECT for Shanks in my mind,
and that is THIS! Just imagine how cool
it would be to have this ENORMOUS red
dragon flying over the battlefield. And
after fighting Kaido for most of Wano,
we all know the awesome powers that this
Dragon form has, with its elemental lightning,
blast breath, wind slashes, and more, but eating
this fruit would also enhance Shanks' strength,
speed, durability, and recovery. On top of that,
can you just imagine Shanks in his dragon-hybrid
form? He’d be super buffed up with his body
covered in red scales and his massive sword. Man,
that would be a terrifying sight for any
opponent. And all this combined with Shanks’
unmatched levels of haki would surely be enough
to take down any enemy in the One Piece world.
EXCEPT Luffy, of course, and now I’m
just wondering who would actually win
in a fight of Dragon forms. Dragon Shanks
or Dragon Luffy? Either way, it would be
an earth-shattering contest, and if you want
to see how Luffy would use the Dragon fruit,
plus all the other Yonko’s fruits,
you can watch that video right here.
Shanks for watching and I’ll
see you in the next one.